I was just teaching the you been
thinking about death Moaning Myrtle
you're one creepy cry-baby and that's
all thanks to the actor who plays you
we're looking at you Shirley Henderson
you're soft and raspy voice has allowed
you to play characters who are much
younger than you are in real life like
that time you play the 14 year old
bathroom ghosts and Harry Potter in the
Chamber of Secrets it's hard to believe
that you were actually 35 years old at
the time that makes you the oldest actor
to portray a Hogwarts student then when
you were 37 you played Myrtle once again
in Goblet of Fire now that's just wild
37 year old actors are used to
portraying high school students and kid
actors are used to starring in creepy
and mature movies but some actors were
just way too old or too young for the
characters they played keep watching to
find out which 40 year old actor
portrayed a high school student in
Pretty Little Liars what's there to be
angry about
I feel like cute did you put them in my
book
Emma Kenny is well known for playing
Debbie Gallagher the good girl gone bad
and shameless she was only 12 years old
when she landed the gig but thanks to
the TV series Emma would grow up a
little too quickly it's no secret that
shameless isn't for kids it has tons of
mature themes and surprising twists
during an interview with vulture Emma
opened up about playing Debbie on a
series she revealed that filming certain
scenes was very awkward for her like
when Debbie had to barge out of the
bathroom and exclaim that she was now a
woman at the beginning of the series
Debbie was a sweet girl who helped Fiona
around the house she took care of her
father Frank no matter how inebriated he
was but by the time Debbie turned 13 she
started acting out she continuously went
after older men and she was obsessed
with getting intimate but the biggest
shocker was when Debbie tricked her
boyfriend into getting her pregnant Emma
had to portray a 15 year old mother on
the show but in real life the actor told
Bolger that she was a goody two-shoes
while Emma was too young to be on such a
mature show she did an amazing job of
portraying the redheaded Gallagher
sister I know who I know Ian Somerhalder
and Paul Wesley played the brothers
Damon and Stefan Salvatore respectively
but portraying vampires isn't the only
thing these actors have in common not
only were they freakishly handsome but
they both played characters who were a
lot younger than them in real life well
if you don't take their vampire ages
into account that is Stefan was turned
into a vampire when he was about 18
years old but Paul Wesley was 27 years
old during the first season of Vampire
Diaries by the time the series aired its
last episode
Paul was 35 years old while he still
looked young he didn't look like the
youthful vamp we met in season 1 and
then there's Ian Somerhalder although
his character Damon received his fangs
when he was 25 years old
Ian was 30 when he first accepted the
role by the time the series wrapped he
was 38 years old and still playing the
dark and brooding 25 year old creature
of the night while we can't imagine
anyone else playing Damon and Stefan
these
jairs were a little too old for their
roles I was impressive but the coffins
aren't here so Oscar winner Natalie
Portman has made a name for herself as
one of the most dedicated talented and
beautiful actors of her generation but
growing up in the front of the camera
wasn't always easy Natalie was
discovered by an agent in a pizza shop
when she was just 11 years old the agent
urged her to try her hand in modeling
but Natalie chose to pursue acting
instead then just one year later she
landed the role of Matilda in the 1994
movie the professional but it didn't
take long for Natalie to realize that
she had been much too young for the role
who do you think this is gonna kill on
kissing monkeys at the time the preteen
had just begun discovering her womanhood
but the movie she started was much too
advanced for her in the professional
Matilda was taken under an Italian
hitman swing when she attempted to
avenge her family problem was Matilda
would go on to fall in love with the hit
man and try to seduce him Natalie
quickly realized that she chosen the
wrong movie to star in when creepy
emails came flooding in to make matters
worse people started counting down to
her 18th birthday because that was when
she would become legal it was all too
much for Natalie and it made her feel
uncomfortable and unsafe Tywin
keep me with you her life Jason Earles
played Miley Stewart's older and
slightly annoying brother on the hit
Disney Channel show Hannah Montana the
show would run for a total of four
seasons beginning in 2006 and ending in
2011 but while Miley Cyrus would be of
an age with her character the same can't
be said about Jason and his character
Jackson in season one of the show Miley
went from being 13 to 14 years old and
her older brother Jackson would go from
15 to 16 however Jason Earles was 29
years old at the time
Jason's real age continues to shock his
fans after all he really did look like a
young teen by the time Jackson turns 19
on the show
Jason was 34 years old what's even more
surprising is that Jason Earles was a
married man throughout the show's run
Jason and his now ex-wife Jennifer had
gotten married in 2002 but they called
it quits in 2013 here at the things we
love ditching out fun facts about our
favorite celebrities if you like getting
all the deets hit that subscribe button
internal notifications for more go into
your YouTube settings and switch on push
notifications if you're watching on your
mobile this way you'll be the first to
watch our latest videos stay tuned to
find out which kid and adult actors were
only five years apart when they start
and Love Actually Bianca Lawson has been
cast as a teenager more times and she'd
like to admit the actor doesn't age like
the rest of us in fact it's almost as if
she doesn't age at all Bianca was born
in 1979 and she portrayed teenage girls
on shows like Sister Sister Saved by the
Bell and Buffy the Vampire Slayer
oh they callin me Kendra but that was
back in the 90s when she was an actual
teenager just like Ian Somerhalder and
Paul Wesley Bianca played a supernatural
character on vampire diary
she would portray Emily Bennett's for a
total of five years and she was 35 years
old when she last appeared on the show
however her character Emily was a witch
whose real age was unknown so she got
away with that one but in 2010 Bianca
was cast as Maya st. Germain in Pretty
Little Liars her character was said to
be around 17 years old
but at the time Bianca was 31 Bianca
you're doing something right if you can
get away with playing a teenager in your
30s anyone who watched Game of Thrones
was immediately smitten by the witty and
persuasive Margaery Tyrell the character
was played by English actor Natalie
Dormer who was 30 years old when she
made waves as Margery I want to be the
queen in the books the character was
introduced when she was 16 but producers
chose to make her 18 years old on the
show Natalie was 34 years old by the
time the character met her demise in the
series which made locking lips with her
on-screen husband all the more
disturbing you see Dean Charles Chapman
the actor who portrayed Tommen Baratheon
was only 17 years old when he filmed
intimate scenes with Natalie who was 32
at the time the so reported that Dean
Thomas was a little freaked out where
the filming scenes with Natalie in the
end the actor found it all to be very
disturbing Dakota Fanning will forever
go down in history as one of the best
child actors of all time but due to her
young age and advanced acting skills the
actor has been cast into roles that were
way too adult for her
in 2010 Dakota portrayed Cherie Curie in
the runways really looks terrible but
despite being 16 years old at the time
viewers felt that Dakota's character was
much too advanced for her age but
nothing compared to watching America's
Sweetheart fall victim to substance
abuse while trying on corsets and
attempting to seduce much older men
although Dakota's performance was
flawless as usual something about the
movie just didn't sit well with viewers
Dakota was much too young to be playing
such as sinister role do you want to be
in the band
are you kidding 13 reasons why is a very
controversial show that has stumped
viewers from the very beginning but
that's not the only thing that has
baffled fans of the show ever since we
first laid eyes on Tony padilha we knew
that something just did not up and it
turned out to be his age excuse me I
don't have a [ __ ] bone in my body in
season 1 most of the Liberty High
students are 16 years old and while the
actors who play them in real life are a
little bit older than that Tony just
didn't look the part
Tony who's portrayed by Christian
Navarro had tons of tattoos and drove a
red Mustang so fans quickly raised their
eyebrows at him and as it turns out they
were right to assume that Tony was
played by an actor who was older than
most of the cast after all Christian was
26 years old when he was cast as Tony
but what's most surprising is that Ross
Butler who plays Zach Dempsey is even
older than Christian he was 27 years old
in season 1 yes back in 2003 Keira
Knightley starred as Juliet in the
romantic comedy Love Actually but
something about this movie just didn't
make sense and that's the age gap
between Keira and her co-star Thomas
brodie-sangster Keira played a newlywed
in the film but as it turns out she was
only 18 years old in real life in
another storyline an 11 year old boy
named Sam continuously tried to get the
attention of his crush Joanna but in
real life Thomas who played Sam was 13
years old it's hard to believe that
Thomas and Keira were only five years
apart in this movie Kira's on-screen
lover played by chiwetel ejiofor was 26
years old at the time which was a much
more fitting age for a newlywed Chloe
grace Moretz is known for her versatile
acting skills but back in 2010 she made
headlines for all the wrong reasons
Chloe was just 12 years old when she
began filming for the blockbuster film
kick-ass and by the time she was 13 the
movie was making waves all over the
world so you want to play but due to the
film's violent nature viewer
couldn't help but feel like Khloe
shouldn't have been given the role
critics took to the Internet to question
the moral compass of the caste people
were outraged that producers would give
the young actor a script containing
extreme language and brutality without
batting an eye however Khloe seemed to
enjoy starring and kick-ass and it helps
bring your acting career to a whole new
level and you'll do anything I say and
that's a wrap before you go tell us
which age gap surprised you the most in
the comments section below thanks for
watching be sure to LIKE and subscribe
for more we'll catch you next time on
the things
[Music]